- Every day my dad's flying
this thing around,
and everybody in all the rooms
are staring out,
being like, "Is that guy flying
a fucking falcon?"
[dark electronic music]
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm Roy Wood Jr.
We all come from somewhere,
from someone,
who nurtures us, protects us,
and teaches us.
- Ah!
[silverware clattering]
- Some are better at it
than others.
♪ ♪
[girl giggling]
- Ow!
[cheers and applause]
You can hear him on his podcast
"Danish and O'Neill,"
Ryan O'Neill,
ladies and gentlemen.
[cheers and applause]
- So my father was
an illegal falconer.
Anybody else?
Is there anybody else in here?
All right, if you guys don't
know what falconry is,
here it is.
So it's been around for
a couple thousand years,
and it's basically people, they
kidnap falcons out of the wild,
and then they train them to
hunt for them.
Now, the popularity fizzled out
with the invention
of the supermarket.
People were like, "Hey man,
I don't know if we need
a bird of prey to bring us
our super anymore."
We can just go to the meat
aisle at the grocery store."
But a group of lunatics kept
this tradition alive,
and my father was one of them.
Now here's the thing: You can
legally do falconry,
but you need a license.
And in order to get a license,
you got to jump through
a few hoops.
Number one, you have got to do
a two-year apprenticeship
with a master falconer.
Now, of all the people that
I could spend two years with,
I think master falconer is
probably at the bottom of that.
After that, you have to build
an enclosure for this falcon
to live in.
Then you need to take
a written test.
Well, my dad's like, fuck that.
Okay?
I'm not gonna let
the government tell me
what I can and can't do.
And so he gets a book
on falconry
and he reads about
three chapters into it,
and then he comes home
with a baby falcon.
To this day, I have no idea
where he actually got this
falcon from.
He claims he found it while he
was hiking through the woods.
Now, I've done a lot of hiking
in the woods,
and I have never seen a baby
falcon just laying there
looking for a good home.
And it seemed like
an odd coincidence
that he just happened to be
reading a book on falconry
and he finds a falcon.
Either way, he brings it home.
But he doesn't have
an enclosure.
He didn't build an enclosure.
So here's what he does.
He reassembles an old dog crate
we have in our living room,
and he throws it in there.
Now, I have to admit, as a kid,
we have a pet falcon,
it's kind of cool, all right.
I had a friend come over,
he's like, "Hey, I just got
a new dog."
And I was like,
"I see your dog,
and I raise you a fucking
falcon, my friend.
Get that dog shit out of here."
But then something happens.
About six, seven months goes
by,
and this thing grows up,
and it is now
a full blown bird of prey.
And I'll tell you this: It does
not want to go back
in the dog crate anymore.
So here's what my dad does.
He lets it fly around
our house,
so right off the bat we let
our cats out one day
and they're like,
"We're out of here.
Like, fuck you guys,
we're out."
One of 'em I think had, like,
a stick with a handkerchief
with his shit filled on it
hobo style and just...
Our dog all day long just hides
under the desk, okay?
He's traumatized.
He's got PTSD.
But here's the worst part.
So this falcon loved to perch
itself on our refrigerator,
right on the freezer door,
so literally every time I went
to go get a Klondike bar,
I had to ask myself, what would
you do for this Klondike bar?
Like, is it worth getting
a talon in your nut sack
for that delicious
vanilla ice cream,
chocolate covered goodness?
One of the scariest things is,
when you would open
the freezer door,
it would just swing open with
it and then just swing close.
No change of expression on its
face whatsoever.
I don't know if it was thinking
of unicorns and rainbows,
or thinking about mass murder
of my whole family.
Now, once a day, my dad has
to take this thing outside
in our backyard, but falcons
don't want to live
in captivity, so here's what
you have to do
to keep them from flying away.
You have to tie a string to
their leg, give it some slack,
and then hold on to
the other end.
By the way, my dad had
none of the falcon gear
that was necessary.
Like, you're supposed to have
a thick leather glove;
he had an old oven mitt.
That's what he would carry--
that's what he would carry it
out into the backyard with.
So we'd hold the other end,
and he would let it go.
And so it was basically like he
was flying a falcon kite
in our backyard.
And it probably wouldn't have
been a big deal,
but at the time,
we lived in a motel.
Yeah.
So my parents thought it would
be a good idea
to buy a motel and then we
would live in an apartment
attached to it.
So every day my dad's flying
this thing around,
and everybody in all the rooms
are staring out,
being like, is that guy flying
a fucking falcon?
And now word's traveling
through our small town
in Indiana, that once a day you
can watch a guy
fly a falcon behind our motel.
And so now we're scared that
something's gonna happen,
because here's the thing:
Illegal falconry,
if you get busted for it,
it's not a slap on the wrist.
It's two years in prison
and a $50,000 fine.
That's insane, right?
You can kill a man and get less
than that.
I didn't know illegal falconry
was like that big
of a problem where they need to
levy these sorts of penalties.
So now we're freaking out.
We're like, "Holy shit,
if he goes to jail,
there's not a lot of
street cred that comes
with illegal falconry when you
get to the big house."
Like, not a lot of dudes are
like, don't rape that guy;
illegal falconer.
He'll fuck you up.
So then something happens.
So, a little twist of fate
happens.
So my dad every day, he would
feed this thing a live mouse.
So he goes to the pet shop,
he gets a live mouse,
puts it on the living room
floor,
and then the falcon flies off
the top of the dog crate,
swoops down and murders
the mouse in front of me
while I'm trying to watch
"Dukes of Hazzard."
Just rips its insides out.
So then one day my dad goes
to the pet shop
and he tried to buy a mouse.
They're all out of mice.
I don't know what happened.
Snake convention in town,
I don't know
how a pet shop runs out
of mice.
So here's what he does.
He has a backup plan.
He has some pork that's thawing
out in his refrigerator,
so he feeds the falcon
some pork.
The falcon eats it,
next morning we wake up,
the falcon's dead.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think they're Muslim
or something.
I don't know the exact science
behind it.
I don't know.
So then my dead reads, like,
three chapters ahead
and he goes, "Oh, shit, you're
not supposed to feed 'em pork."
So now we have this dead
falcon,
which I got to be honest
with you,
if you're getting two years for
just having a live falcon,
if you murder one, it's
probably way more than that.
So now we have to wait for
nightfall to come.
We march out into the woods,
my brother and I dig a hole,
we bury it like ten feet deep,
and my dad was just so
brokenhearted about this.
He was devastated.
He thought that he was
super tight with this
fucking falcon.
By the way, he was not tight
with this falcon at all.
This falcon didn't give a shit
about him.
But my dad, he never gave up,
man.
He tried to get other falcons
unsuccessfully,
and he passed away last year,
which is why I'm legally
allowed to tell this story now.
But one of the last
conversations I had with him
was in his backyard,
and he was grilling,
and there was a falcon
that actually lived in his
neighborhood.
And it was soaring overheard,
and he was looking up at it,
and then he just turned to me
and he goes,
"I'm gonna catch that
motherfucker."
And then he died.
Thank you guys!
Thank you very much.
- Ryan O'Neill, everybody.
Ryan O'Neill!
[cheers and applause]